la liste continue de s'allonger
après les émirats arabes unis le bahreïn
et le soudan le maroc devient le
quatrième pays arabes depuis août
dernier à promettre de renouer
officiellement des relations
diplomatiques avec l'état hébreu
le premier ministre israélien a
immédiatement salué cet accord
j'ai toujours cru que cette journée
historique deviendrait réalité un jour
j'ai toujours oeuvré pour cela je veux
remercier donald trump pour ses efforts
extraordinaires pour avoir mené la paire
ni israel et les peuples du moyen-orient
ce nouvel accord a de nouveau et est
passé sous la médiation de donald trump
le président américain a fait part de sa
satisfaction à six semaines de son
départ de la maison blanche
cette reprise officielle des relations
diplomatiques entre le maroc et israël a
sans surprise été condamnée par le hamas
au pouvoir dans la bande de gaza le
mouvement a dénoncé un péché politique
alors que rabat était fortement
impliqués dans le règlement du conflit
israélo palestinien
cette annonce survient également sur
fond de tractations diplomatiques
tendues au sujet du sahara occidental
le président américain a ainsi annoncé
avoir signé une proclamation de
reconnaissance de la souveraineté
marocaine sur cette ancienne colonie
espagnole en territoire revendiqué par
le front polisario qui réclame que soit
organisé un référendum
d'autodétermination prévu depuis la
signature d'un cessez le feu avec rabat
en 1991 le mouvement indépendantiste a
fait part de sa colère
le polisario et le gouvernement sahraoui
condamne dans les termes les plus forts
le fait que le président américain
sortant donald trump attribue au maroc
ce qui ne lui appartient pas à l'opposé
de la réaction du mouvement sahraoui
le roi mohamed 6 à lui salué une prise
de position historique des états unis
concernant le sahara occidental malgré
les appels de l'onu à trouver une issue
politique les négociations impliquant le
maroc le front polisario l'algérie et la
mauritanie sont au point mort depuis
mars 2019